deep in the forest of azerbaijan there  are bears birds and  a restaurant  what is  so this restaurant visionary got to work  this great big story was made possible  by  azerbaijan tourism  [Music]  khan lar karamov is the owner of  restaurant gabala khanlar once he set up  shop he also became the forest protector  [Music]  this is  he began training with khan lar when he  was a young chef and he knows good food  chopping meat on a tree trunk is how he  makes his signature kebabs  [Music]  a shepherd's dish that was long  forgotten until khan lar stepped in it's  made by cooking meat between two stone  slabs  for both these men the secret behind  this dining adventure is simple be the  foreign  [Music]  foreign  [Music]  you